if you haven't filed your taxes yet now
is the time the deadline is this monday
april 18th but if you think that you're
scrambling you should know the irs is
too does that make you feel better they
are backlogged they are under staff what
does that mean that your refund could
take a little while
scott mcfarland is outside irs
headquarters has more on the story scott
we should remind people that government
workers at this time are having a tough
time too right
yeah gail good morning the irs admits it
is over tax this year as well still
trying to dig out from last year's tax
filings and at one point they were
taking 1500 phone calls per second
dave weinberg is always connected and
says he can run his maryland business
from his home computer while walking the
dog or even on a snowy spring day at the
park so he finds it particularly
frustrating he spent so much time on
hold trying to reach the irs you can't
even get them on the phone three weeks
at a time
and you couldn't get them on the phone
for weeks at a time weeks at a time
i mean it was tax season and that's not
an excuse though they're chronically
underfunded in a report to congress last
week the irs acknowledged only about 20
percent of callers have been getting
through to live irs agents at times this
month and that's actually an improvement
over 2021 when just 11 of calls were
answered it comes as the agency
navigates what it considers a perfect
storm
more than 3 million tax returns are
still being processed from 2021
budget cuts and coveted disruptions have
shrunk staffing to less than 80 000
people the same level it was nearly half
a century ago while more than 16 million
people roughly 10 percent of taxpayers
still file on paper which the national
taxpayer advocate calls the agency's
kryptonite often the people processing
the paper are the same ones who answer
the phones on average you know our whole
times can range anywhere between 30 and
40 minutes the irs's ken corbin says the
agency is hiring new employees and
contractors to lighten the load but
won't see most of the impact until
future tax seasons how many more do you
need i would say you know we need
thousands more employees still coming to
join us
we are an aging workforce
and we know that we have to prepare for
the future
even as the tax season ends the irs is
hiring thousands of new workers and
having job fairs all across the country
in a tight job market where it's
difficult to find applicants who have a
knowledge of the tax code if you are
scrambling this weekend the irs strongly
advises you file electronically and use
direct deposit
tony
we'll help you get that refund more
quickly scott thank you very much